Serge Lama as-tu trompé ta femme
alors Serge Lama comme vous êtes passé
pas loin de la mort lors de votre
accident je vais vous faire une
interview jugement dernier c'est normal
[Applaudissements]
Serge Lama
ah tu volais de l'argent dans le
porte-monnaie de ta maman quand tu étais
petit
jamais c'est Bécaud
à ma mère c'était compliqué parce que
vous savez elle était très Provin et
puis
j'ai piqué des sucres
Serge Lama
as-tu copié sur ton voisin en classe
pendant les compos oui
Serge Lama
as-tu enfermé des élèves du sexe féminin
dans les cabinets
non
non mais j'avais j'avais une sale manie
quand j'étais à la maternelle
pas déjà mais je piquais des petites
filles avec des épingles
et ça est-ce que tu te repends pour ça
oui oui Serge Lama
as-tu pardonné à ta mère oui
Serge Lama
as-tu déjà été tenté par l'homosexualité
non et j'avais mon meilleur ami qui
était homosexuel et quand comme ça
marchait très mal quand j'étais môme
avec les avec les jeunes filles un jour
j'arrive et puis je dis j'en ai plein
dans une faire [__] j'en ai marre et me
dire mon pauvre coco on peut pas avoir
toutes les chansons en même temps
Serge Lama as-tu fait l'amour sans désir
de procréer
tu te repenses tu dirais même que des
fois je l'ai fait volontairement pour ne
pas procréer Serge Lama as-tu trompé ta
femme
c'est ta dernière chance Serge Lama
c'est le jugement dernier
tu veux entrer au
paradis
être avec ma femme c'est entré au
Paradis Serge Lama as-tu trompé ta
maîtresse
[Rires]
Serge Lama
as-tu vraiment fréquenté les petites
femmes de Pigalle et ben non
non moi je suis plutôt type à bourgeoise
oui je suis un peu non
tu préfères les femmes mariées oui comme
ça tu les as pas sur le dos toute la
journée
Dieu peut rigoler pas forcément marié
mais aussi oui d'accord Serge Lama ah tu
exigé des femmes des pratiques contre
nature j'ai pas exigé mais j'ai je leur
ai demandé quoi gentiment elles ont dit
oui pas toutes
c'était
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu